Roxana Saberi has been digging into
those communications between Rudy
Giuliani President Trump and Ukraine's
president she's in Kiev that's Ukrainian
capital Roxana we heard that you have
new information on the content of those
talks what can you tell us good morning
Ukraine's president said this morning he
will not be releasing a transcript of
his July 25th phone call with President
Trump a former adviser to Ukraine's
president told us it was a quote
well-known fact here that President
Trump was looking for compromising
information on Joe Biden and that
Ukraine's president believed US aid to
his country was at stake I'm sure that
issue of Biden was forever on the table
between szalinski and Trump as a former
lawmaker an advisor to Ukraine's
President Vladimir Solinsky sir he
Lysenko believes it was clear that
President Trump wanted Ukraine to
investigate his Democratic rivals of
course he wanted political privileges
favors for his reelection from Ukraine
in return for military aid I would say
yes do you have any evidence of that it
was like well-known fact in Ukraine in
2016 leshenka was at the center of
exposing Paul man affords dealings in
Ukraine he says he recused himself from
working for zalenski in May this year
after it became clear that could
threaten relations with the Trump
administration Ukraine relies heavily on
US aid in its war against Russia in July
Trump ordered nearly 400 million dollars
of that support withheld days later in a
phone call he asked Ukraine's president
to investigate the Biden's according to
the whistleblowers complaint mr. Trump's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani made or
attempted contact with at least seven
Ukrainian officials including then
prosecutor general yuriy lutsenko
Sanko told the BBC Giuliani asked him to
investigate the Biden's have you got any
evidence that Joe Biden acted in any way
which supported hunter Biden's company
or is mouth it is not my jurisdiction
under Ukrainian law you've got nothing
much
certainly but leshenka says the two men
were circumventing official channels
he told us Giuliani also tried to set up
a meeting with president-elect zelanski
but Solinsky said no because he realized
everything about this story was toxic
Tony Roxana Saberi in Ukraine Forrest
Roxanna thank you very much